hi there steve kaufman here again
um
i'm continuing in my series of
frequently asked questions about
language learning
uh some of you follow my blog the
linguist on language some of you are
members of link
um i'm i talk from my own experience not
from any great scientific research
it may surprise some of you that one of
the questions that i am asked most often
is
should i learn several languages at the
same time or should i just focus on one
at a time
now many of you have probably
you know not yet succeeded in learning
one foreign language to the level that
you would like so you may find it
surprising that people are asking me
about learning multiple languages
but in fact you know once you've
conquered your first language
you very quickly start looking at a
second and a third and a fourth
foreign language to learn
it's not that difficult to do once you
get the hang of it
so what's my take on this
uh you know all of these things depend
on your individual
you know preferences and so forth
i find it difficult to concentrate on
more than one language at a time
that is to say if i'm starting a new
language or i'm still
in the middle of that period where we're
trying to achieve a certain level in the
language i find it difficult to take
myself away from
my main love
to then focus on another
you know
predilection so to speak so
uh i'll typically go very hard at one
language and and i believe there's value
in intensity that the more intensively
or intensely you pursue a language the
better so if you have an hour a day to
spend on language learning or two or
three or half an hour whatever it might
be
i think there's an advantage in focusing
that
on that one language so the day after
day after day you're with that one
language i think you're going to achieve
more
i will sometimes sort of go 80 90 on one
language and then spend 10 20 on a minor
language which you know in the case say
of portuguese is so similar to spanish
that it's it's kind of less effort
but i find it difficult to take myself
away from my main
uh preoccupation my main love at a given
moment which for example for me for the
for the last three four years has been
russian
uh i may get away from that and move on
to something else
so it's entirely up to you i know there
are people who
simultaneously study three or four
languages
i would recommend that you at least
focus on one for a given period of time
whether it be three months six months
give it your best shot go at it with a
lot of intensity then leave it whatever
level you've achieved there and go on to
another one a few other bits of advice
if you leave a language after three or
six months you won't forget it if you
study another language when you go back
to that first language you will actually
find that you've improved i found this
over and over again yeah you'll be rusty
at first but
studying a second or third language is
all part of improving your ability to
learn languages and when you go back to
that
first language the second language the
first foreign language you will have
been you will have improved so there's
no danger in studying two or three or
four languages whether you do them at
the same time or whether you do them
sort of in sequence i prefer to focus on
one at a time so there you have it
that's my take on studying multiple
languages i hope that's helpful
i should add let me know what questions
you have and they can be general
questions about language learning or
they can be specific questions about how
do i deal with the subjunctive in
spanish or the you know case endings in
russian or any specific language problem
that you have learning the characters in
chinese whatever it might be let me know
what you are interested in so thank you
for listening